quick question for you why would you
encourage people to firebomb my van why
would you do that
do you think that's appropriate to
encourage people to Fire Bomb my van and
hurt my crew when we're just expressing
a difference of opinion as a matter of
fact we have your pictures right here of
your tweets of your posting our location
right now let's follow that from either
not KJ so is that the way you deal with
civil disagreements so this doesn't
bother you you're okay with encouraging
violence against people I just want to
make sure looking for one condemnation
anyone to have an opinion on encouraging
acts of violence I discourage them
across the board the violence against
her by posting her face everywhere and
trying to get people to hurt her
okay I've never done that what
this is her asking people to bomb my van
you're you're strong with the mob but I
should be ashamed of yourself that's an
apology would be nice
you are a coward though you can see how
big of a man you are you want to go to
the restroom